what's going on everybody today I'm
going to show you how to program a smart
key without needing a PIN code for this
2020 Toyota Corolla we've got our
working key right here
and then key that needs to be programmed
we're using the autel im508 we're going
to start out by going to the immobilizer
menu
where we will select our vehicle
go to Toyota
go ahead and
turn on the ignition
[Music]
get automatic selection
see what that comes up with
all right so there's our Vin hit okay
2020 Corolla
all right guys so you're going to want
to make sure that you got
good battery
level top right corner but this is what
we're going to do we're going to go do
control unit keyless system
first step is going to be to back up
immobilizer data via OBD
so turn off ignition
turn on hazards
all right so
[Music]
we'll hit okay
I'm gonna back up the
prom data
you notice it says that this allows us
to do immobilizer functions without pin
I'm going to show you how that's done
this might take a moment
now I mentioned that about the battery
level because I've done this before on
some Toyotas with
usually less than 11 volts or they're
pretty low and it'll start throwing
codes make the computer freak out if you
clear the codes everything's good to go
but just be mindful of that
okay so where's our eprom file
going to go to
there hit save
so now we got the immobilizer data
backed up we're going to back out and go
to add smart key
[Music]
only four keys can be learned
turn on the ignition
[Music]
is on
I'm going to go ahead and hit OK
[Music]
ignition off
turn on hazards
[Music]
so it says number of Keys has reach the
max let's see how many are in here four
so this is what we're gonna do now you
got to be very careful doing this
because you can
delete keys
and then
you can't get them back in there
so we'll go to erase keys
notice it says that the key is not close
to the start button will be cleared
cannot be learned again so here's our
learned key we do not want that deleted
turn on ignition turn on the hazard turn
off the hazards
ignition is on
guys I really want to show this step
here because you can screw this up
turn off the ignition turn on hazards
[Music]
we have backed up the eprom data
foreign
so it's our bin 20.
now it's going to use this pin to
erase the keys take our key that we want
to be working
put it near buzzer
buzzer will beep it has beeped once
so that key is going to be learned back
into the car
any others the other three are no longer
going to work
in addition to not working
you will not be able to reprogram them
into another vehicle
so don't learn that the hard way make
sure you have them all ready to go in
your hands
so now we got one key
see if it still works
[Music]
I'm gonna close this door
stop that beeping
all right so we're still good that key
still functions that's what we want to
see let's go back to add smart key
maximum four can be learned
turn on the ignition
ignition is on
[Music]
let's get some Focus back in on that
all right okay
there's our van
please check yes that's our bin
turn ignition off
hazard lights on
okay
yes we have backed up the eprom data so
that first step I showed you in the
beginning
this is how you get by this is how you
get past the PIN code
so
be mindful you don't have to pay for PIN
codes on these
so there it is reading pin
key programmed key
close to the start button
it's this guy right here
little beep once
beep twice
so we're gonna let it time out here
should tell us to turn on the ignition
and put the key back up to the button
one more time
so let's go ahead and do that
put learn key close to start button
it's our new one
you heard that beep learning succeeded
so if everything was done correctly
let's make sure they work
turn ignition off
this is our new key
let's check our old one
and we'll fire it up see when it
when you unlock the vehicle that padlock
goes away
so we'll put our foot on the brake
make sure she fires up
[Music]
those look like some programmed keys I
hope that helps guys remember don't pay
for your PIN codes on this newer Toyota
system smart key let's back up your
mobilizer data get the PIN code that way
remember that you do have a maximum of
four keys and if you're gonna delete
Keys these cannot be reprogrammed or
refurbished so I recommend OEM new only
thank you hope this helps